in the year 1900 this little pocket
watch cost 250 dollars yeah today it's
worth six thousand dollars is it a good
relative investment how do you know
when you buy this that is authentic
it's over 100 years old how do you know
with certainty
[Music]
I think the modern watch Market is gamed
in any way given the information that's
shared which isn't much from the
manufacturers given the way the
retailers have these tight relationships
with their buyers
I mean it's ripe for problems especially
in a world of social media it can sway
opinion how is the market gained in your
opinion
the Skeptics say it is game I say no
it's a it's an open auction open cry
auction I argue that let me give you an
example of um recently a large collector
that had a very large number of Jordans
that he collected over
um
over a 20-year period brought a huge
number to Market at once in one day now
if the market was gamed and you thought
that Jordan had somehow achieved these
astronomical price appreciations over
the last four years that market would
have collapsed with over 20 pieces on
the market
that's not what happened some of them
got record prices and so
when you the the auction Market keeps
everybody honest you know everybody
keeps saying well I'm not going to buy a
Patek I'm waiting for prices to collapse
well good luck
like that's just not going to happen
there's an insatiable demand for almost
every piece some more than others as you
well know the collections come out every
year people scramble they try and make
their decisions early they put their
markers in the smart collectors ask once
that's it and they show their
indications then I tell them shut up
sit and wait
now with so much data supporting the
growth in the value of watch collections
why do you think more people aren't
looking at watches as an asset class for
example we've seen other categories fall
we've seen what's
happened.com historically I've seen
different other assets that I won't
mention now to collapse but what about
watches they seem to weather the storm
when there's these ups and downs all
around why aren't more people jumping
into the game
I think over time they will but the
reasons watches never collapse the same
way other asset classes is they skip
Generations
people are proud to wear their fathers
or mothers watch and because they skip
Generations they have an imputed value
of perpetuity and the the aftermarket
for supporting watches and and repairing
watches and maintaining watches is a
multi-billion dollar industry in itself
ensuring them everything else it's
because of the emotional attachment
people ascribe to something that a
parent owned and and that will be
forever and so that what you find later
in life is is your children start saying
well look you know
we know eventually what's going to
happen to you can we talk about your
collection and which ones are going to
stay in the family and which ones aren't
and I've actually had that conversation
with my with my kids I mean you can
start to see
recently something else has happened and
this goes is for the pro case of watches
many of my pieces
that what women would have never worn
are now worn by my wife and daughter
they borrow them all the time huge 41s
and millimeters and and that's part of
fashion part of style and indeed they're
even buying pieces that are larger now
and women were you know originally 36
and under and and so we're seeing a lot
of change in the in the market but I'm
actually thinking that it's it's a
I'm seeing more and more younger men and
women in their early 20s and I have a
very very large social media base so I'm
constantly in dialogue with them
early 20s saying I want to get a watch
of the Red Band I mean what brand do you
think I should I should buy first and
and I I I get right into that dialogue
with him and I always say them don't
borrow money do not put this on your
credit card
if you have a target find out how much
it is save it buy it own it you'll
remember it forever
you know a lot of that dialogue goes
around Brands like Tudor Grand Seiko
um there's some amazing omegas that are
just collectible and yet affordable
all up to that
if you have a certain amount of money
let's say five hundred thousand dollars
yeah what percentage of your net worth
should be in watches never more than 20
okay and no one watch should represent
more than five percent of your net worth
ever if you're buying watches in the
millions of dollars you better have
millions of dollars because that's an
you know that's a very first of all
getting at getting access to that means
you shouldn't be reselling it until
you're dead so that's going to be a
long-term asset like a bar of gold but
no watch more than five percent of your
net worth and watches in total no more
than 20 of your net worth and I follow
that rule like crazy
you're the first person I think to share
publicly an opinion on what percentage
of your net worth should or could be in
watches and you've also shared that 5
million is a magic number in your mind
yes when you hit five million dollars I
put it in your words what happens when
you have five million dollars you have
set yourself free for the rest of your
life
um you have to understand that when you
put that money into a watch it has no
yield other than capital appreciation so
if you're you have to decide what your
lifestyle is going to be and what you
need on an after-tax basis and by your
dividend-paying stocks and bonds to
provide for that but you can also buy
long-term assets and I recommend watches
as be one of those just like gold some
people like Bitcoin I mean there's all
kinds of alternative asset classes and
when you think about the context of a
portfolio and I say the same thing my
mother taught me this if I look at my
stock portfolio which is a huge part of
my net worth no more than five percent
anyone's stock no more than 20 in any
one sector so I don't own more than 20
tech stocks you in my real estate
portfolio real estate's unique in the
sense that some people let it become up
to a third of their net worth but that's
also a heavy maintenance cost for all
those buildings and condos you own so
you have to have balance and and you
need diversity no different in the watch
collection side of your business but you
get so much camaraderie and so much joy
and you know I'm going with my wife on a
tour of Japan of course I own a creedor
so I want to see where it was made that
for those of you well you would know
what a creedor is yes I've toured the uh
the factory yeah it's incredible
incredible and of course I put it up
there in terms of when I when I wind one
of my pateks and I want my my crador
they feel the same to me so this
remarkable workmanship in the Creator
and of course we're with the Jordan
Society
um if you're if you own join watches you
get past three you can petition the
society to join if you're a real
collector we'll open you know welcoming
with open arms and you can join us all
around the world as we pursue our
you know in watch collecting in horology
that's what we do so each of these opens
the door to a country club it really
does and you know here's a here's
another Jordan I think you've seen
um I mean this is a beautiful piece it's
black because I'm a collector I mean
Jordan is very they only make 900
watches a year so you have to petition
to get it I waited two years for this
piece uh I don't know if you've seen
this Marin this is the Tutti Frutti our
good friend Bill put me on to this oh
yeah I think there's only six of these
it's a crazy dial I mean you know
speak Marin very nuts
um the music which you know is I think I
talked to you about this watch it's an
overseas so it's not as coveted as
um you know a Royal Oak but since I've
been wearing it around the streets of
New York I've had like 20 offers to buy
it apparently you can't get these
anymore that dial makes a statement it's
a huge statement it's rock and roll baby
right there that is just gorgeous it's a
beautiful piece it's a lot of fun uh
this is the one of a kind I talked about
that was at the auction last December
from chapard The Laughing Mexican smell
of death it's just nuts that is gorgeous
is that engraved yes it's hand engraved
there's only one of those it's eight day
Reserve power Reserve I mean it's a
crazy piece you have to find the hour in
the teeth
wow it's it's very good so if you have
20 of your personal assets and watches
not you I'm just saying one as 200
percent
you protect yourself for authenticity
theft and all that goes around it just
like keeping them safe day to day well
after you have 50 pieces you're not
going to keep 50 in your home very few
people do you go to a vault system with
banks and I do that in multiple
countries so I have an inventory control
system I know what's sitting in
Switzerland I know what's sitting in
Miami I know it's sitting here in New
York I know it's sitting in other cities
I travel with about 17 pieces that's it
and I insure those specifically I have
Arrangements when I am traveling with
them that they're in a secure evolved
I'm I wear three to four watches a day I
start with a morning watch I switch at
lunch there's an afternoon piece and
then I decide what I'm going with for
the evening otherwise I could never go
through my collection I mean what's the
point of having a collection people that
buy watches keep them in their box and
never bring them out
that's when the watch actually loses its
Soul it dies it dies it's a dead watch
it's you haven't shown it respect it
never got out and never saw the daylight
it can't speak to its watch Brethren I
mean that's insane you have to wear the
watch that's why and if you're actually
I frankly think that the watchmakers
know
that you're never showcasing the piece
and and I think that puts you down at
the bottom of the list in my view I
don't know that was certainty but you
know this is a different you've seen
this as a Rolex this is they don't make
that anymore but that was the original
sort of Classic All Steel white face
Daytona and then of course you can see
it again with the ceramic and I have the
white for that too I mean everybody
wants these pieces they're just the
hottest watches out there it's crazy but
and with a red band of course they're
Shark Tank Classics I I auction my I had
a Daytona that went for over 60 000 for
charity with Paul last December they're
all storytelling pieces and you know I
oh then of course let's talk about this
uh New Edition yes John
um Aaron I actually own this now for two
and a half hours I left the meat packing
Rolex store where
I went to pick this up I believe it to
be only one of three in America there's
one rose gold there's one white gold and
there's one yellow gold this is mine the
yellow gold
I mean I was expecting something unique
because I'd seen so many images of it
um this is the puzzle or Emoji watch
supposedly a day-date but it does not
display any days or dates
when I first saw this piece I thought it
was an AI hoax and so did everybody else
um I called my contacts at Rolex and
they said no it's no joke
I said it has to be no one would ever
approve that at Rolex I know Rolex they
said no you don't now you've been proven
wrong they've done it again they've kept
the classic look with a completely
insane new idea for a dial
now if you're a dial guy you have to
have this I'm very very fortunate I'm
very fortunate to have one of three when
I saw it for the first time it blew me
away I thought it was going to be a 10
it's an 11.
it's a 36. I have not seen one of these
in person because they're not out there
yeah but I'm really struck by the
quality of the enamel is it true of
cloisonne enamel yes it's true that it's
also each puzzle piece
is encapsulated in a gold ring and
that's what pops the cast in the light
that's all I can see Sapphire is Mark
the time I mean it's in a crazy piece
but for Rolex it's completely shocking
yeah
and so I'm so proud of them to just come
out of the left side and just go bang
deal with this so now I have a whole new
respect for them I mean now I'm looking
for some like this is a crazy dial where
else can we go with Rolex I mean it's
got me excited in Rolex like I haven't
been in years
I can't wait to wear this on TV tomorrow
I'm all over the networks I'm wearing
this I think it's going to be nuts it's
a conversation starter it is I think it
has a great place in the collection it's
going to be as soon as I get a red band
on it it's going to be a big hit on
Shark Tank but I'm not going to wear
this with a red band often just because
I have to do it for continuity on Shark
Tank this President
band is just beautiful with it and you
commented you love the president
bracelet which is the most classic
identifiable bracelet and what's my
favorite of what Rolex has made classic
and it's never going to change it it's
just spectacular I mean there's I have
so much respect for the history of Rolex
keeping that look intact decade after
decade after decade and yet
experimenting with something like this
it's been great I mean just it just it
it reinvigorates me to just when I left
the store I said look you guys keep
doing what you're doing I'll just keep
buying now get back to work now each of
these watches have a wonderful story
personal they have also an economic
story uh as as an asset they're all
appreciated in value they've all go in
the right direction up they all have
boxes and papers which I'm sure you have
storage oh that is you know I think
about I didn't even talk about the loose
from Patek I mean this is also
incredibly hard to find oh you don't see
those no you don't but you know why it's
got a red band a factory Red Band I got
down on my knees and begged for this
piece because I've been chasing Patek
for 15 years to let me put red bands as
you know that never happens in Asia they
released a couple of pieces once with a
red band this was a North American
release
I I I I just I had a I only asked once
but with such passion
they they must have felt the electricity
a red Factory band are you kidding and
who knows maybe that red strap was
somewhat inspired by what you have been
doing I know red bands are on the rise I
like to think I'm part of that movement
I mean you know red makes dials pop and
it just really works with a black suit
and I wear a uniform I'm wearing the
same suit on Shark Tank for 15 years
I have 25 of these suits it's with all
the moving Parts in in your collection
and I mean that as a pun do you think
there's a place for physical assets to
be tied to nfts for example it's a topic
we've discussed before where do you
stand on that question today
I would very much like that digital
documentation but I have come to the
realization as I know you have John in
talking with every single brand about
nfts this is not going to happen
overnight it's going to take decades and
a standardization will take decades the
use of nfts I I have now come to
inclusion the idea of trading in nft
away from a watchmaker
zero chance of happening because
I remember having this conversation with
FP Jordan himself and he just looked at
me in horror
wow so
they can see it as a methodology for
ensuring the watch authenticating the
watch as a form of travel papers with it
but the idea that you're going to get an
nft that you can trade away from the
original piece I don't think we're going
to see that in our lifetimes it's artist
writes question oh it's beyond at large
rate the idea that the soul leaves the
watch and somebody else owns it yes I
I've seen the look of horror on on the
watchmaker's faces they just look at me
and say
what are you talking about
it just seems increasingly obvious that
someone's going to get it right of how
to tie each of these watches to
Something in web 3-0 it might not be
called in nft but it's going to be some
sort of digital pair and I can't wait to
see who gets there first and how that
develops I'd love to be part of it and
I've tried to invest in it and I want to
be part of it
um I think it'll be a very interesting
part of ensuring a watch because you
could actually with the nft say here's
my location I only ensure the 17 I'm
traveling with I don't need to ensure
the rest there are in vaults under the
streets of Zurich I mean good luck
trying to steal those but my point is I
want to have
these insured for something happens and
I want them ensure that their resale
value
um today's market and so we have not
achieved that yet in the insurance
industry we have a lot of work to do
particularly when you're talking about a
piece like the Emoji or or the loose you
know from Patek I mean the or any FP
Journal I mean when I talk to insurance
companies what fbjorn they're saying we
kind of get our head around that capital
appreciation like and when they talk to
Jordan about replacement he said there
is no replacement I'm not making that
watch again and I'm done anytime you do
a one of a kind this is irreplaceable
yeah there's never again one of one one
of one and so
when I talk to insurers they say no
we're not insuring that you just should
never wear that anywhere
and that breaks my heart so here at
collectibility we've identified and
defined four different types of
collectors I want to tell you what those
four types that fall into what category
and then I'd like you to tell me which
one you think you are most
number one the treasure hunter number
two the Speculator number three the
accumulator number four the researcher
which one are you
wow is there such a thing as being both
yes yeah
I think I'm the accumulator and the
researcher
um I have no interest in speculating on
watches I I'd be honest with you I don't
know what I paid for these I really
don't
um I don't remember because I don't care
I just know that I didn't borrow money
to buy them I do know what they're worth
every day because I keep that for
insurance purposes and I Mark to Market
like I do every asset I have
in my office we Mark to Market our
entire portfolio we run money for the
state of North Dakota we do all that
every day it's automated
that's when I started to notice as
accumulator the capital appreciation was
going crazy in the last four years and I
started calling around saying what's
going on here
and is is it a is it a fake Market is it
a manipulated Market an uncomfortable
conclusion it's not so I'm going to say
accumulator and and researcher because
boy am I deep in the Weeds on new
watchmakers and
you know one-of-a-kinds I have another
one of a kind coming an incredible piece
from that piece Jordan I'm so excited
again waiting years for it my trouble is
I'm going to die one day this is a big
problem well then you're taking them
with you I think you've already settled
then yeah so what's what's your dream
watch is there one piece that keeps you
up at night someday will be coming your
way
I I would say right now what I'm really
anticipating
um
is that Jordan I've been waiting for
vertical Tribunal
um although I have been looking at his
Francis Ford Coppola and we are I mean
that piece is have you seen that piece
the hand yes yes yeah yeah that's he's
only making three a year of those so you
know when you know a watch is close to
being completed the anticipation
it said Carly Simon's song
anticipation that's what's that's what's
happening with the Jordan so right now
that's on top of mind for me I'm
planning receiving it going to go to
Miami for it um
you know I generally do social media
when I'm receiving the watch and we and
we put it out there for people to see
and enjoy uh that's pretty on my mind
but I have to admit this Rolex has got
me just in a tizzy if that's a good word
I'm going to be wearing this for a while
because it's just too cool I mean
there's nothing like this in my
collection and so it's going to be a
listen you got to add it to him we're
saying it again they've really knocked
it out of the park with this thing
I think that is now my favorite modern
Rolex
and I think and I would agree with you
because it just
until you hold it and you feel it and
you see it and the way it pops the way
that they've done a masterful job on
that dial whoever made that dial I mean
free hot dog for that guy it's fantastic
what about vintage
where do you stand on collecting vintage
watches and do you think that could be
your next step well I did buy a world
timer a vintage World timer 175 Edition
um very complicated getting that piece
I just love the dial they stopped making
it as you well know that black dial I
just went through
so much work to find that piece and that
was sort of my
foray into the Patek vintage I've been
buying vintage Omega for quite a while
and Cartiers for because they were early
watches for me and I had a couple of my
collections stolen so I have to replace
them one at a time I know all the pieces
and I've searched the world and the
Interpol records and everything else
there's something sheer evil about
stealing people's watches I mean it's
just and I've had it happen to me twice
so you know inside jobs and everything
else and so now I really concerned
myself about my security systems you're
going to have a really hard time
stealing my watches whoever you are out
there they're just never where you think
they are and that's you know how it
works people think they're going to go
to my home and find a watch never
it's a good reminder that uh collectors
should insure their watches protect
their watches and don't assume the
assumable yeah exactly but when I ask
about vintage
kind of I go back a little further I
have this this piece here so let's go
back 125 years yeah
particularly pocket watch yeah
now what do you what are your thoughts
and feelings when you hold a watch such
as that in your hands which is
significantly older than what we have
here yes I mean by miles but it's
remarkably well built and how beautiful
it is which goes to the legacy of what
Patek has always been Master watchmakers
but
I have never found my way into
pocket watches not yet anyways because
I'm so down the road of of you know
traditional watch collecting but I
understand why people get this virus too
um and in the world everybody knows
you're the guy for this because
how do you know
when you buy this that it's authentic
if it's over 100 years old how do you
know with certainty and that's the
beauty the extract from the archives
yeah and so you are the archive guy well
Geneva has them you pay them 500 Swiss
Francs they give you movement number
case number describes the dial in detail
and you have essentially a historic nft
on your hands so that's but but only you
I mean I would never buy a piece like
this unless you were involved because
who else can you trust I mean it's sort
of
imagine you're a major collector and you
get duped
yes I mean that just that would
devastate me that's one of the reasons
I'm so concerned about like you know
they say 10 of daytonas in the secondary
Market are fake like I don't have a
secondary Market Daytona and what's
incredible you could take any of these
to service at the respective companies
and you're going to find out well you
know they're all 100 correct
what's amazing with these you could take
them to protect the leap they'll service
anything from 1839 and that's when you
find out if everything is correct and
will will they authenticate prior to
purchase can you do that no that does
not exist so you is there any way how so
how do you get someone to open it and
look at it if it's a piece you don't
know in other words what concerns me is
all of a sudden a very important piece
shows up on the market like a John
Lennon Patek nobody knows where it is I
would buy that watch if I could but I
would want to know with certainty that
it was his because everybody's going to
fake that piece exactly so how do you
how do you authenticate and that's where
collectibility comes in it's knowledge
scholarship connections forensics and I
want to put the F first for forensics
right it would be very hard to fake that
watch for example because we know when
it was sold where it was sold we know
where it is there's a lot of things that
you need to do you know where the John
Lennon is uh I will comment on not off
camera absolutely kidding interesting
all right that's my first no comment on
uh yeah I lost to something here so stay
tuned
but I want to talk numbers on this so in
the year 1900 this little pocket watch
cost 250 dollars yeah today it's worth
six thousand dollars is it a good
relative investment
what year was it 200 yeah I saw 124
years ago
I would say yes for this reason it's
probably going to start accelerating in
appreciation as more people get into
that so you're buying it for that's a
relatively benign acceleration you've
probably calculated the irr in that it's
low
you can't look at it like that in the
sense it's like buying gold right 120
where will it be in 20 years that's the
question yeah yeah and I would bet as
more people get into pocket watches that
Patek would be the gold standard period
for pocket watches I mean I'm trying to
think of another brand that is more
coveted than that but it's just the
demand for pocket watches is a smaller
vertical it's a smaller vertical it's a
very small yeah there's probably a 25
people in the world that control 80
percent of the really of the highest of
the highest of the highest the highest
yeah so all right we're in the home
stretch now yeah have you ever had any
horological regrets any mistakes that
you've made I have made mistakes to say
that I've never made mistakes I've let
in pulse uh
buy pieces that I'm not that I'm I'm not
proud that I own
that never happens to me anymore but I
learned as a young Buckaroo that you do
need the research piece you do need the
emotional connection with the dial you
it needs to feel right
um
I've talked to many collectors about
this you know I I for a while was was
having a hard time getting my head
around
something like the eye of the tiger from
Rolex or even the loose from Patek
because it included diamonds and
emeralds and other
it took me about 10 years and now I
really appreciate the artsmanship of
creating pieces like this and I wear
them proudly and I love them for their
their just celebration of color and
everything else but it took a while and
so you better feel good about what
you're doing because you're spending a
lot of money and you're making an
emotional connection and you want to
wake up you know my biggest challenge
every day as I go through the portfolios
which 17 for this month
which ones or which 17 for this week or
which 17 for tomorrow you know I when I
go to Shark Tank next week I'm going to
arrange for security we're going to go
through with wardrobe let's look at 100
and pick seven like
think about how how hard stressful in a
way well they all have to be different
okay they all have to have red bands
they all have to be unique and they
can't look the same so I'll come up with
something amazing but that is work
so let's talk a little bit about Shark
Tank and horology
my kids and I love watching Shark Tank
and we've been watching you for for
years it's 15 Seasons now right it's
just incredible but the only horological
story I could think of and uh
and I curse Shark Tank to this day
there's a something called Clocky there
was a a woman that came on her name was
gory Nanda who made this thing called
Clocky which is an alarm clock that
rolls on the floor makes all these
noises and lights you have to chase it
in order to get out of bed literally my
youngest daughter has one every morning
this is what starts my day like a shark
tank for that so so thanks for that a
successful product a great product magic
of having 100 million people see your
product and syndication on Shark Tank
because you sell a lot of stuff yes I
mean it's a it nobody ever expected this
to happen it's a remarkable platform now
have you ever been pitched a watch
company on the show yes we have yes yes
we have yes we have
um
I believe that one didn't air because as
I pointed out it was bastardizing
watches okay which to me is unforgivable
I think it's I just
I you just can't do that I mean you're
disrespecting the maker yeah and the
brand what are you doing like if you
ever want to become a collector and
you're opening the piece yourself with
some Rogue mechanic
you're finished
do any of the other sharks understand
watch collecting or watch culture
I I think
the one that's closest to
um
would be uh hershavik he is he is a a
big big Rolex collector and as respected
as one but diversity of of of of uh of
dial no I mean
you know everybody always says to me
please get me a Rolex I mean I hear that
every day and I get it but that's not
I'm not I mean Rolexes are so important
and they've cheat to get that level of
brand globally it's just but to collect
watches is to respect all the makers now
have you ever noticed a nice watch on a
guest on the show that's bitching to you
many times and I'm starting to notice
red bands on them Ah that's clever yeah
it works yeah that works if you're
listening out there sucking up works
that is fun now in just in your business
dealings like in life do you notice
watches in the boardroom when you walk
in do you notice what people are wearing
that's I don't notice them it's the
first thing I look at yes I if I can't
see the piece I say can you lift up your
cuff I want to know what you're wearing
it tells me everything about you yes
everything and so if you don't think
wearing a timepiece isn't part of who
you are as a person and a brand you're
crazy I mean
your watch is an extension of who you
are and your personality and you should
think about that that's why I've changed
so many times a day what am I feeling
like for lunch where am I going for
dinner what's happening at breakfast
meeting what do I want to show when I'm
on this TV show or that TV show
this is the whole deal it's it's the
storytelling of watches this is why I'm
into this and when you know and if you
know there's a very popular electronic
watch out there and if that's all you
got
well shame on you I've recently watched
your well this I think it was eight
months ago uh Harvard Business School
asked you to speak and it was one of I
think the most engaging conversations
you had with a group of highly
intelligent highly motivated students
and then some of them actually pitched
for you but you told and gave them some
advice on a pitch and that's the fact
that you're you're watching them you're
looking at eye contact yeah but now
you're telling a number two what if
Kevin O'Leary's secret hints of success
your watch says everything about you so
eye contact in your watch yeah but if
you you only have one chance to make a
first impression and the time piece
itself
says everything and it also tells you
what kind of a person you are I know the
difference between a Patek person and an
AP person and a Rolex person or or a
journal person my goodness you want
eclectic people like I mean my goodness
so if I see a journal on you you could
be a brain surgeon you could be an
astrophysicist you could be an artist
you could be a painter you know you
could be guitarist I mean
that company goes out of their way to
diversify who owns their pieces nobody
hits me up more than
for Assurance and all I can do is bring
them to meet the Jordan people
um
I'll tell you a great story he's
probably going to kill me for telling
you this but
Jay surris who is probably one of the
most renowned agents in Hollywood
UTA if not the number one guy
particularly in the news industry
got into watches and he had them before
I met him but but I passed the virus to
him and he got diseased
and he started seeing my Jordans out in
Hollywood and he just
just went crazy he was calling me four
times a day
I said look Jay it's not going to happen
you can't just March into a genre
Boutique and say I'm Jay sures I want to
join
they don't care who you are they don't
care how much money you have it just
doesn't matter he said
I'm Jay surace I'm the best agent in the
world I have to meet FP
I said you got to be kidding me like he
is he doesn't care it doesn't matter he
said I just want to meet the man that
makes these watches
I said okay Jay
I'm in New York I'm going to the
boutique tomorrow he's flying in from
Paris we're doing a dinner
happen to be on the street outside I'll
make the introduction because you're not
getting in the boutique
son of a gun he was waiting outside on
the street oh my goodness
he owns two Assurance today see a little
panhandling goes a long way you know he
made an appeal that they're
underrepresented
in the media industry of managing media
not Stars they've got plenty of people
on insurance but the people that manage
the industry I believe Jay sures is the
first
to have of that caliber of manager to
own two Jordan's and and FP respects him
for that so now he has found his way
into being ajorn collector this is what
I'm talking about this is the magic of
collecting and the brand and the history
and the person in the story this is what
it's all about all about human
connection that's it well Kevin I can't
thank you enough for spending this time
with us today I was able to ask so many
questions I have more for you afterwards
which we cannot uh we're going to talk
about the John Lennon Patek yeah so the
rest of you have to go away and I'm
going to find out for this conversation
this conversation is going to continue
great thank you congratulations I really
enjoy success fantastic thank you so
much always a pleasure we could talk
watches for two days in a row let's do
this again the pizza that's it